you also have kind of became one of like
the main guys that like hip-hop artists
will tap into if they need a verse or a
hook I mean work with guys like fabulous
and go on and on who are some of the
well first of all being as a a guy who
went to college here was born in Atlanta
has there been a hip-hop artist you've
worked with where you were like damn
that's crazy I got a record with this
guy like this is crazy
definitely definitely it should be oh I
think well I mean I have a lot of you
know records I didn't have one with me
but one of the records I was like yo it
was nice oh when I got that Naz verse in
Hit Boy Studio like that was one of the
moments because my brother you guys met
him at head boys yeah he just came in
the room I was like what Ah that's what
he's like yeah man like he likes African
music oh thank you thank you thank you
what you working on and he just laid the
verse of me and my boys just looking
because that was special to me because
my oldest brother Nick he was a big Mass
fan like that Illmatic album Still A man
Stillmatic of course when he was young
in his face yeah he's right there it's
behind that box oh wow see yeah that's
crazy so that was like crazy to me and
then obviously like with Thug you know
yeah baby oh that was real dope ain't no
we connect you know you ended up
connecting and like really vibing with
Doug yes oh
like not even on music tip you know I'm
saying Thug is Thug's a great guy man I
actually met a little baby through Thug
before little baby even dropped a record
oh really she's back in the day people
don't understand like Young Thug and
Gucci are like two of the best a R's
ever crazy they just always have like
just Talent around him like and and we
all we'll all be in the studio and you
know when when you're like in the studio
and everybody's like playing their music
everybody passing the aux cord when I
put I play my
they always loved it so I always knew
that man this genre is going to go it's
gonna go yeah that's right what was it
did when you guys worked together did he
record the verse with you there yes
because I heard his process is pretty
crazy yeah he
he um
but baby
baby
it's like this they're gonna write
nothing down right it's just does he lay
the uh he lays he lays the melody first
and then punches in and go back punch in
go back do the melody then you know you
get the words that you record it you
know I kind of record the same way too
so you're you're kind of similar well
you'll lay a Melody down and then fill
in the lyrics Melody and feeling the
lyrics oh yeah you used to be an
engineer yeah which way do you prefer to
record an artist because I do know some
Engineers that get frustrated we're like
yeah punch me in backpack backpack no no
right there punch me and punch me think
about me you got to be quick
because I get anxiety when you know when
you have an engineer recording you they
got to be fast yeah you have to be very
very quick and I don't sleep so it's
like you got to be quick quick because
you know where you want to
you know lay down an idea you know first
of all you don't want to lose it right
because sometimes it never comes back
you know what I'm saying so I like to be
kind of quick yeah for you uh how much
how much like of your own production are
you doing these days none actually none
yeah recently but
um with this last album
um I like I supervise the production
right I'm saying but I'm not as Hands-On
as you know I was you know years back
um what it's like for you give me two or
three artists that are on the come up
right now that we should be checking out
in the states
um
who's on the remix of that song Selena
Gomez yeah
um
kiss Daniel
a lot of people man I can I can name a
hundred females you know we got Thames
we got Iris star tiwa Savage so yeah we
doing great